he's a spiritual leader and founder of
the Art of Living Foundation
he teaches that spirituality enhances
human values like love and enthusiasm
for his service he's received some of
the highest awards from several country
he's Sri Sri Ravi Shankar and here's my
take on his top ten rules for success
volume 2 rule number one is my personal
favorite and I'd love to know which one
you guys like the best and as always as
you're watching if you hear something
that really resonates with you please
leave it in the comments below
hopeful to run it to other people can be
inspired as well and when you write it
down it's much more likely to stick with
you as well enjoy life is not flowery
not buttery I tell you so many talents
life has so many challenges but the
wisdom or knowledge equips you to face
the challenge the difficulty is when you
think life should not have challenges
the challenges will appear even much
bigger to you life has challenges but
wisdom equips you to face them why do
you want everything to be easy take some
challenge challenges are necessary in
life what do you think so huh everything
is so easy so boring see how people go
up on this mountain and jump from the
cliffs with a hand glider it's a
challenge some people want to go and
scale Mount Everest someone says oh I
want to sail through the world these
little challenges people take it you
take some little small challenges in
life how to deal with uncertainty turn
back and change your own life how many
times you have felt like that
how many times have spent worrying when
things have all happened right right in
the right manner so looking back at your
own experience you should say this is
futile to worry about it yeah
second is you should do have confidence
in your own ability and in your own
fortune you should know that only the
best thing will happen to me it will
happen to me but confidence if these two
things doesn't work there is a third
option he note the Valor in you tell him
come what may I'll face it I will handle
it I have the power to handle you know
spirituality is uplifting the spirit to
your consciousness money is for your
comfort money give brings you comfort in
your material level you know we we are
spending half of our health to gain
wealth and then we spend half of our
wealth to regain the health
I usually doesn't work so taking care of
your health because health is the best
wealth one can have is part of
spirituality and with money I would say
if you are think money should be kept in
a pocket not in your head if you keep
thinking about money all the time you
can't even enjoy the money that you have
produced so money is needed but
something which is more necessary than
money is that humaneness is that
happiness that when he cannot buy stop
the mind know it's racing it's always
thinking about the past or anxious about
the
future we are angry about the past or
anxious about the future to take a fresh
look at the world to the situation you
need to wake up and see as Matt Miranda
used to say that I will never turn back
and look so now let's see what we should
do now and for the future that gives a
lot of energy encouragement enthusiasm
and lifts you up from the ashes even
though there are ashes our action has
some film imperfect maybe 1% of 80% or
90% some percentage of mistake these
arrests as a tonight when you notice it
you recognize a wise man accepts a
mistake but a fool doesn't see the
mistake at all my food chemist blenders
but doesn't see the mistake of anything
someone points it out he doesn't accept
he becomes defensive this is what a fool
does he know the Vice mainly feces
mistake in a dish he helps them to come
out of it in a compassionate manner but
the fool takes pride in others mistake
if fully so happy if someone else does a
mistake and he announces the route that
person did a mistake that person the
domestic we have some very talented
people but they have certain minus
points if you look at the - fine state
Alan's Oscar
isn't it so you don't see a very perfect
person and but your intention is to see
everyone is perfect when you are looking
for perfection in everybody around I
tell you you forget to see the
imperfection inside us we want
everything else to be perfect as you
mean that perfection chapter your father
then you see that you have effectively
stopped pointing out and get frustrated
about artistic effects if we are
frustrated about others imperfection we
cannot contribute to their growth then
becoming perfect this is the red dilemma
what we want others to be perfect
organizations to be perfect Nations to
be perfect people to be perfect and in
this one they forget to see how we can
improve us a little what you say right
so when we start looking within a whole
new dimension open surrender join is
never between good and bad you know
there is no choice between water and
sand if a cup of sand is kept under cup
of water you don't say which I want to
drink
he will definitely doing water if your
choice is only between water and juice
you drink whatever both are necessary
for life so when you think which I will
get more joy your greed makes your
choice very difficult when you're not so
greedy so never mind now I will take
what a little later juice you'll feel at
ease with it
there is no choice between good and bad
at all and once you know this is bad you
will never choose it because it is not
so then you don't know it is good or bad
then use your sense that which gives you
long-term happiness short-term problem
is to be chosen that which use a short
term happiness and long term problem
should be discarded but it so be in this
world enjoy this well yet not get caught
up drowned in it keep yourself little
aloof and saying he keep yourself
untouched by the external save your soul
save your mind save your spirit save
your joy don't get it get that muddled
by the events in the world are you are
you getting what I'm saying don't let
others or any events take away your
freedom take away your joy and your
inner peace this is art of a you found
you we used to clap
right in the same way in the world in
day-to-day life so many events come to
put down your enthusiasm but never give
up when your right to candle and put it
upside down what happens that the flame
go down or goes up flame always goes up
right like that life is light life is
the burning flame as you see that it
should always go up yeah even there are
100 reason to be unhappy
we should overcome them all and who can
do it only you can do not it so but no
point don't give up your happiness or
enthusiasm now what is a way to be happy
by sharing happiness spreading when you
spread happiness it grows when you don't
read to spread it to hold on to yourself
it dwindles windle's
dwindles and then finishes this is what
people don't know they want to be happy
where they don't know how to share with
everybody how to expand one's family
thank you guys so much for watching I'd
love to know what did you take from this
video what was the most important lesson
that you learned that blew your mind
that you're going to immediately apply
to your life or your business somehow
please leave it down the comments below
I'm super curious to find out also if
you want to nominate someone for the
next top ten video please check the
description for a link to a video where
you can vote for people and put in your
suggestions as well I also want to give
a quick shout out to behind go peanuts
thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book your one word I really really
really appreciate the support and I hope
you're enjoying the read so thank you
guys again for watching I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon
there are four ways to deal with a
person who doesn't who is doing things
which you don't like of it are you ready
to listen to it first is forgiveness so
okay
and tell them don't do this again okay
now it doesn't matter anyway it's
happened but please don't do this again
gentle forgiveness second time and they
do it you should show indifference so
you know indifference because you are
repeated it I am NOT I'm not going to
accept this
this is indifference don't talk to me as
third time as they repeat you simply cut
off move away take some distance if they
repeat on the fourth time then you take
a stick if you really want what you are
aiming at hold on to it you know but if
you feel it is worthless putting so much
effort and I what I am going to achieve
by that then you move on to something
which is much easier yeah you know once
there was a short term prime minister in
India he said Rudy now I am Prime
Minister I find for this I struggled all
my life I find it's meaningless
before I could sleep here happily see
now there are 50 policemen guarding I
can't even sit outside my own home in
the farm life is futile he says it's a
futile struggle all my life
I said even to understand this it took
you so many years anyway at least now
you realize many people don't even
realize at that time what is happening
with all these dictators and rulers in
North Africa they're all killing
thousands of people just to hold on to
power
this is stupidity at least our gentlemen
Indian Prime Minister had the sense it
was futile game I said you are lucky in
this sense so like that if you want to
really achieve it so hard then put all
your life to achieve it but you find
something else is better to put your
energy go in the direction you know
India has a long history of spiritual
upliftment when you see that everything
is collapsing and there is all doors are
[ __ ] and there are no hope no deeper and
depression sets in India gives a vision
of you know something higher and the
possibility the power of your own
thought the power of your mind and how
you can create your reality or world and
move in that direction you may not be
successful immediately tomorrow but the
vision and the mission always takes you
forward